[Music]
April is a special month for this
channel it's the one-year anniversary of
the first video it's the month we first
surpassed 1 million views and it's also
the month that I got to meet a lot of
people in person that I know from this
project at ng-conf in Salt Lake City
this video marks episode 104 we're going
to do something a little bit different
than normal I'm going to spend some time
answering questions that you've asked on
slack and YouTube that wouldn't normally
fit into this channels content but
before we get into that I just wanted to
say thank you to everybody who supports
this channel either with a pro
membership or just by simply liking and
watching the videos
it's your feedback that really drives
the direction of this content and I'm
really grateful for that to show my
appreciation I'm going to provide 10
free t-shirts or gift cards to anybody
that comments on this video with a
suggestion about what they want to see
next just leave a comment and I will
randomly select the winners by the end
of this week okay so now let's jump into
question number one
how was ng calm I have been to quite a
few tech conferences in the past and
most of them are pretty boring but I'd
have to say ng comm stands out as being
extremely well organized and engaging if
you ever get the chance to go it's well
worth the investment
but what I really want to share is my
top five most exciting things happening
in the angular world number one by far
for me is angular elements this allows
us to build angular components and use
them as custom elements in HTML without
bootstrapping an entire angular app this
opens up an entirely new paradigm for
angular development where we can focus
on building components and then drop
them into existing applications for
example if you have a Ruby on Rails
application you can build an angular
component provide a script and then use
that component in your rails app it's a
total game changer for angular
developers number two is the new IV
render engine the first thing it's going
to do is dramatically reduce bundle
sizes with advanced tree shaking
techniques it can Preston minified hello
world app is only 2.7 kilobytes which is
extremely small but if that's not enough
it's also going to dramatically improve
debugging capabilities if you've ever
seen the expression has changed after
it's been checked error then you
probably know that it's very frustrating
to debug but IB includes a much improved
stacktrace that will take you exactly to
the point in the
template where that error occurred so
very much looking forward to IV and
version six I'm also looking forward to
rxjs version six if you're like me your
components probably have twenty
different lines dedicated to rxjs and
ports and that's because there's
hundreds of different import points in
the library but in version six there
will only be two main import locations
which will dramatically reduce the
number of lines of code it takes to use
rx in your angular project now moving on
to number four is the new vs code live
share mode which was announced at
ng-conf this feature allows multiple
people to collaborate on a document in
real time similar to how Google Docs
works this means that you can pair
program remotely on a shared document
which opens up the door for all kinds of
cool stuff with education and just
teamwork in general the last thing I
want to show you is a new feature from
stack blitz called teleport it will show
you real-time changes happening to your
app across all devices so if you're
building a PWA on your desktop and you
want to see how it works on a mobile
device you can do that using teleport
stack blitz will give you a URL that you
can load up on your iPhone and then you
can see the changes happening in real
time similar to how real-time features
work in firebase that wraps up the top
five for me but make sure to watch all
the talks on YouTube because there is so
much great stuff that I just wasn't able
to cover here I want to switch gears to
a question I get asked frequently which
is how do you make your videos the first
thing I do is I write a bunch of code on
my Ubuntu workspace and make sure that I
have a solid working demo before doing
anything else from there I have a
special patented technique that I use
for recording code snippets what I do is
I delete things in reverse order then I
click record on my camera and then hit
control Z or undo to rebuild the
function step-by-step once I have those
recorded I use Adobe Creative Cloud to
produce the video mostly Adobe Premiere
but also Adobe After Effects for certain
animations I create the videos on
Windows but I also have a Mac which is
equally effective at producing videos
the next question I want to address is
what is a Cordova plug-in which was
asked by Hayden on our slack channel
this is a great question because Cordova
plugins basically feel like a black box
and we just kind of trust
that they're doing what they're supposed
to do the underlying problem that
Cordova plugins solve is that we want to
use JavaScript to interact with SDKs
that only understand Java Objective C
Swift and Kotlin
so a Cordova plug-in can be thought of
as a bridge that allows us to use a
JavaScript interface to write code that
normally only runs in these other
languages that native mobile apps
understand if you look at the source
code for a plug-in you'll see that it's
code base is normally split between
JavaScript and then Android and iOS code
you'll generally see a file for iOS
which is going to have some objective-c
files then you'll see an android folder
which generally has some Java files on
my future video list
I have building a capacitor plugin from
scratch which is very similar to Cordova
but that video is probably still a
couple months off the next question
comes from Raul on YouTube I've never
used a state management library should I
learn ng rx or ng XS but I think a much
more important question is do I need a
state management library at all because
both libraries will add additional
overhead and complexity to your
application in an effort to make complex
state more predictable and easy to test
there's a good scene in the react world
that says you don't need redux until you
know you need redux and i think there's
a lot of truth in that I have a
QuickStart lesson for both so test-drive
them and see which one fits your actual
coding style and the Preferences of your
team the final question comes from
Pierre on slack and that's how do I
build an online shop with angular and
firebase the beauty of the angular
firebase stack is that it affords you a
ton of flexibility but at the same time
it helps you build things quickly and
reliably whenever building something
involving payments or e-commerce I
recommend leveraging a third party API
because building this from scratch is
something that's hard to pull off for
most businesses stripe payments for
example gives you a ton of tools to
implement your own e-commerce solution
but there's a bunch of other
alternatives that you should compare and
contrast such as Square Braintree and a
new one called Bolton that I haven't
actually tried but it does look very
interesting what's really interesting is
now that angular elements is on the
horizon it opens up the door to use
angular components and platforms like
Shopify so you could use the underlying
platform for
or e-commerce solution and then add
interactivity on top of it with angular
elements I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up here if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and don't
forget to leave a comment for your
chance to win a free t-shirt or gift
card thanks again for your support and I
can't wait to see what the next 100
videos will bring
[Music]